bonjour nous sommes le vendredi 4
septembre nouvelle édition de votre
journal d'information locale voici les
principaux titres que nous allons
développer comment se passe l'accueil
des réfugiés dans le département les
premiers sont arrivés en milieu de
semaine à bonnel les associations sont à
leurs côtés notamment le secours
catholique et relais du swing président
en ile-de-france invité aujourd'hui en
plateau ce 10 septembre s'est ouvert à
paris au grand palais le salon des
métiers d'art et de la création de 160
exposants et parmi eux un versaillais
jean sablé à rencontres à suivre tout à
l'heure et puis nous reviendrons sur le
reste d'actualité locale depuis ce début
de semaine dans les yvelines de la
dégradation de l'oeuvre d'anish kapoor à
versailles à la mobilisation des
buralistes contre le paquet neutre de
cigarettes est l'invitée fil rouge donc
de ce vendredi hervé du soul bonjour et
bienvenue en plateau vous êtes le
président du secours catholique dans les
yvelines et en ile de france nous allons
largement évoqué avec vous la situation
des réfugiés mais tout d'abord cette
information qui nous est arrivé en début
de journée un détenu de 41 ans a été
blessé jeudi soir après avoir mis le feu
à sa cellule de la maison d'arrêt de
bois d'arcy la victime et cinq
surveillants légèrement intoxiquées ont
été conduits à l'hôpital du chesnay et à
la clinique des franciscaines à
versailles
on parle de politique à présent les
élections régionales se déroulent les 6
et 13 décembre et chaque formation
occupe le terrain pour les républicains
à poissy david douillet chef de file des
yvelines pour ce scrutin vient d'obtenir
un nouveau meeting vous le voyez est
thèmes abordés sans surprise les
transports il l'a évoqué manque de
sécurité rénovation en retard et pertes
engendrées par la mise en place du
fameux pass navigo à tarif unique
ap à stabio à tarif unique pourquoi pas
la gratuité
total dans les transports parisiens j'en
rêve on n'a pas les moyens aujourd'hui
la taille fait que la tarification
unique du passe navigo qui comme par
hasard tombe là à quelques mois avant
l'élection
comme par hasard pour moi c'est une
décision c'est de l'irresponsabilité
politique pourquoi parce qu'elle n'est
pas financé aujourd'hui monsieur
bartolone avec monsieur kalfon cherche
le moyen de financer ces 200 millions
d'euros qui manquent
le bilan après dix sept années de
gestion régionale par les socialistes
il est catastrophique sur tous les
niveaux mais en particulier au niveau
des transports et du swing et le
président de secours catholique dans les
yvelines je vais pas vous faire réagir
sur le pass navigo à tarif unique mais
plus globalement sur ces régionales qui
approchent et sur l'engagement des
politiques
est-ce que vous en tant que responsable
en ile de france du secours catholique
vous avez des attentes particulières
qu'est ce qui vous fait passer des
messages parce que c'est un peu le jeu
avant les élections tout le monde veut
faire passer des messages aux politiques
passer des messages s'est pas
directement mon rôle on dialogue très
régulièrement avec les politiques en
dialogue avec des maires les députés
conseil général bon et dans un dialogue
en principe constructif on essaie de
trouver des solutions
cela dit c'est pas parce qu'à des
élections aujourd'hui que l'on va
particulièrement adopter une attitude ou
une autre il y avait un point
particulièrement important pour vous ce
serait quoi sur lesquels vous entendez
des engagements pour les régionales plus
particulièrement
on a devant nous une fracture
territoriale extraordinaire entre des
zones où la richesse est importante de
d'habitat et puis des zones dans
laquelle toutes les pauvretés sont
concentrés donc c'est vrai que c'est un
sujet d'aménagement du territoire
si on laisse faire de façon naturelle
les tendances qu'on observe les zones
pauvres vont devenir de plus en plus
pauvres
et on aura un véritable une forme de
ghetto c'est clairement là on a 100
interventions sans intervention on va
dans ce sens là dans tous les cas de
figure donc il est urgent que de façon
sur des choix politiques
on est des arbitrages qui soit fait mais
le certain nombre de communes qui
refusent de façon systématique tout
habitat social et toute ouverture au
social
bon ça pose des problèmes quand même oui
on verra si vous êtes entendus sur cette
cette demande avec la campagne des
régionales qui se poursuivent qui se
poursuit par dont 6 et 13 décembre pour
le scrutin vous restez en plateau on va
changer d'univers on va parler culture
juste le temps de partir pour le grand
palais ou en lin versaillais c est
installé depuis jeudi jean sable et
artisan peintre en décor versailles et
participe au salon international des
métiers d'art et de la création
le reportage est signée sephora namani
et patrick jacques de dixmude jean sablé
a fondé son école de peinture décorative
voici 12 ans à versailles sacré meilleur
ouvrier de france
il entend former des professionnels
internationaux à cet art un art au large
champ d'applications
il participe actuellement à la deuxième
édition de la biennale internationale
des métiers d'art contemporain au grand
palais du 10 au 13 septembre
j'ai vraiment envie de
je dirais de moderniser ses techniques
de la peinture des trafics ltte les
dévoiler au public
donc avant tout je veux montrer qu'on
peut on peut faire évoluer les métiers
d'art leur donner une autre dimension
une perspective et c'est le premier
objectif de ma présence ici on peut
modifier pour tirer ou du moins changer
les aspect décoratif esthétique de
versailles sans renier versailles sans
renier cccc décor met vraiment en lui
faisant vivre au 21ème siècle
scènes de genre trompe-l'oeil
chinoiseries et panoramiques sont autant
de techniques décliné dans un style
classique ou contemporain jean sable il
réalise sur des chantiers d'envergure
internationale tels que l'ornementation
de résidences privées aux états unis au
sultanat d'oman ou encore au ritz la
dernière réalisation c'est ça que j'ai
pu faire sur le plafond de l'hôtel de
rites ses impros faible à fond de la
piscine
il s'agissait de peindre en
trompe-l'oeil 200 m² de
de ciel donc c'est une
une réalisation qui a été menée
conjointement
avec trois autres collègues peintre en
décor et donc c'est vraiment un très
très beau projet très ambitieux vraiment
très bien accueilli par les personnes
qui me l'ont commandé pour jean sable et
le foisonnement des échanges de notre
siècle notamment sur les réseaux sociaux
fait écho au foisonnement artistique des
16e et 18e siècles caractéristiques du
mouvement baroque et puis cette autre
information la guerre des cinémas qui se
poursuit en région parisienne annonce
avec la ville de maurepas pourrait avoir
son multiplexe ou comme celle de
coignières au grand désespoir des
équipements déjà existants sur elancourt
et trappes leurs voisins on vient
d'apprendre qu entre versailles et le
chesnay le torchon brûle également la
commission départementale d'aménagement
commercial vient de retoquer le projet
de 12 salles que l'ugc souhaitait
implanter au centre commercial parly 2
du chéné parce que les élus de
versailles qui siège dans cette
commission n'ont pas pris part au vote
le maire de versailles qui explique
qu'il souhaite défendre forcément les
salles de sa commune qui seront
d'ailleurs prochainement rénové
on passe à présent à l'essentiel de
l'actualité de la semaine que s'est il
passé dans le département sur saint
quentin en yvelines et alentour voici un
résumé en images
roll hall of nous avons usé de tous les
moyens de transport voiture bateau de
sauvetage
c'est ça après ce long voyage et après
tous ces kilomètres et ces pays est ce
que le monde a vu à budapest
c'est le début d'une victoire pour nous
d'être ici en sécurité des partenaires
locaux convoqué l'on va s'adresser leur
dire et si on semble un effort on n'est
pas obligé pas en accueillir quinze
vingts familles mais on peut être
accueillir quelques familles et puis à
l'échelle de l'agglomération
il ya des associations il ya des
services des villes qui peuvent
peut-être faire plus d'efforts que
d'autres en fait on est contre le paquet
neutre
marisol touraine qui qui veut en fait ne
pas faire une différence entre le paquet
neutre est le paquet générique le paquet
générique c'est ce qui a été voté par le
parlement
donc tous les pays européens auront 65 %
de mentions tracteur mais marisol
touraine avait toujours faire plus parce
que c'est selon l'air du temps tu es tu
leur mieux pour mieux faire que mieux
faire que les autres
donc il veut faire 100% du paquet
en mention sanitaires c'est à dire que
plus aucune marque d'afficher plus aucun
logo et plus aucune couleur
selon pardus et j'ai pu paraître et
cigarettes il faut l'arrêter
définitivement ya pas de produits
cigarettes qui circulent dans l'étape
française
l'actualité de ce lundi dans les
yvelines c'est là sculptures d'anish
kapoor au château de versailles encore
vandalisé des graffitis à caractère
antisémite ont été réalisés dans la nuit
de samedi à dimanche sur dirty corner
l'oeuvre polémique sur nous mais aussi
le vagin de la reine l'artiste a fait
savoir qu'il comptait laisser son oeuvre
en l'état déclarant que ces mots
infamants faisait désormais partie de
son oeuvre
non seulement ça me choque mais ça me
fait peur une telle violence une telle
intolérance
on aime ou on n'aime pas mais on n'est
pas obligé de regarder mais la rentrée
s'est très bien passé là on a fait
rentrer les preuves des premières au
quatrième année on les étudiants qui
avaient connu le site de levallois était
particulièrement content il arrivait
dans des locaux tout neufs
c'est vrai que nos locaux de levallois
était relativement siens et puis
beaucoup plus étroit donc pour eux c'est
l'occasion d'imaginer à une façon de
travailler qui est beaucoup plus
collaborative beaucoup plus d espace d
ateliers selon pierre bédier la ruralité
est troublée bien qu'ils se défendent
d'être dans une démarche électoraliste
il confesse en substance une certaine
inquiétude quant à la présence d'élus fn
sur près de la moitié des cantons
yvelinois au deuxième tour des élections
départementales
il s'agit de dire que à l'occasion des
élections les habitants il exprime une
colère donc il faut essayer de
comprendre cette colère de l'analyser on
peut pas dire que ça soit les sujets
d'immigration qui est marquée ces
cantons
le projet de doublement et raccordement
dupont vise à désengorger le trafic
améliorer l'efficacité des bus et
l'accessibilité aux gars estimé à 11
millions trois cent cinquante mille
euros
il est financé par l'état la région et
le département l'agglomération participe
à hauteur de 1 million neuf cent
cinquante six mille euros et pour la
mairie de maurepas l'enveloppent s'élève
à 834 1000 euros la principale
information de cette semaine elle ne
concerne pas uniquement ni saint quentin
en yvelines et ses alentours ni même le
département ça va au delà c'est
l'arrivée des réfugiés en france on va
en parler avec vous à présent pour le
secours catholique les migrants arrivent
en masse le président françois hollande
a annoncé pouvoir accueillir jusqu'à 24
mille réfugiés sur deux ans un chiffre
qui s'ajoute déjà aussi mille réfugiés
dont l'accueil avait été acté avant
l'été est ce que ce chiffre est ce qu'un
un chiffre tout simplement c'est
suffisant est-ce qu'il faut limiter
l'accueil des réfugiés suffisant
suffisant le par rapport à un flux
massif qui arrivent non bien sûr non la
réponse est non c'est mieux c'est mieux
que
les premiers chiffres annoncés moi
j'avoue que j'avais été un peu désespéré
pendant la totalité de l'été on parlait
absolument pas d'accueil ou parler
exclusivement de la manière de fermer
les frontières de rendre étanche de
notre pays et l'europe avec certains
pays encore aujourd'hui ça se passe en
comptant certains pays bon alors il se
trouve que maintenant depuis la fin du
mois d'août et début septembre commence
à réfléchir autrement j'espère qu'on va
poursuivre dans cette voie et que petit
à petit on va prendre conscience de
l'ampleur du problème qui est encore
très largement devant nous 78 réfugiés
qui sont arrivés dans le département
cette semaine c'était à beaune elle vous
en avez vu les images il ya quelques
instants et on va les revoir
le secours catholique a été associé à
cette arrivée vous avez participé
non on a été mis au courant mais on n'a
pas été directement associé pour
l'instant nous on a des équipes qui
prennent contact avec ces migrants de
bonnel notamment pour regarder ce qui
aujourd'hui leur est fourni et ce qui
leur manque
donc il s'agit pas du tout de
s'incruster entre guillemets mais si
j'ai de voir exactement quelles sont les
problèmes on sait qu'ils y sont en
principe pour à peu près un mois bon à
plus ou moins quelques jours
et qu'est ce qu'ils deviennent après on
n'en sait rien donc et d'autres doivent
arriver encore dans le département dès
la semaine prochaine elle sans doute du
côté de versailles puisque la préfecture
des yvelines a demandé à la ville de
réquisitionner le centre des mortemets
qui héberge habituellement les
militaires de passage là vous serez
mobilisez vous serez sur le terrain vous
vous préparez c'est arrivé parce que
effectivement ça a été très médiatisé
sur les premiers arrivés mais ça va se
poursuivre sur les prochaines semaines
alors vraisemblablement oui
la seule chose qu'il faut bien retenir
c'est que ce qui se passe au moment de
l'arrivée est à peu près prévue
organisée
bon c'est ce qui se passe après kylie
absolument pas aujourd'hui on a des tas
de bonnes volontés qui s'exprime alors
qu'on n'a pas grand chose à leur fournir
en terme de
récupération mobilisation de leurs
besoins beaucoup d'appels de gens qui ne
sont pas fait normal
on a on a énormément d'appels sur
l'ensemble de l'île de france et sur les
yvelines aussi on a des appels de tous
types de personnes qui proposent
quelques heures par ci par là d' en tant
que traducteur interprète entendent
hébergé en tant qu'hébergeur en est
ainsi de suite donc bon c'est bien c'est
bien mais il va falloir tenir et tenir
dans la durée là dessus l'enjeu est
effectivement vous le dit depuis tout à
l'heure c'est après après qu'est ce
qu'ils vont devenir ces réfugiés le but
c'est qu'ils s'intègrent en france et
qui le rejoignent leur pays qu'ils
partent dans un autre pays
alors aujourd'hui on n'en sait rien de
façon très concrète
il est plus que probable qu'un nombre
important d'entre eux soient amenés à
passer plusieurs années chez nous c'est
à peu près évident que ce qui est fait
en ce moment et ce qui est organisée
c'est leur arrivée pour vérifier d'où
ils viennent leurs droits et ainsi de
suite établir une feuille de route une
certaine manière mais à partir du moment
où on les considérera comme des réfugiés
c'est à dire oui seront en france de
façon légale
en gros c'est débrouillez vous quoi
emploi logement
bon c est là pour le coup le travail des
associations va devenir extrêmement
important vous avez développé le réseau
wellcom c'est pas propre à l'arrivée des
réfugiés aujourd'hui comment ça
fonctionne ce réseau wellcom alors
willcom fonctionne déjà depuis un bon
moment comme a été lancé ces initiatives
jésuites et les jésuites se sont souciés
de cela il ya maintenant pratiquement
une dizaine d'années dans l'accueil de
réfugiés et le principe c'est de
d'accueillir un réfugié chez soi pendant
à peu près quatre semaines de façon à ce
qu'il n'y ait pas de de fixation que la
famille ne se sentent pas
personnellement responsable de du
réfugié en question et au bout de quatre
semaines et il est invité à allier
d'aller dans un autre un autre domicile
l'objectif c'est de créer autour de lui
un climat d'accueil et de reconstruire
une espèce de cellules amical et
familial qu'il a forcément perdu en
quittant son pays
et puis dans le même ordre dans le même
temps
donc la famille ne l'accompagnent pas
mais un accompagnateur est dédiée à
chacun tuteur migrants à twitter voilà
est donc mis le tuteur suis la même
personne de famille en famille de façon
à avoir la continuité de la relation est
donc vous appelez des familles bien
évidemment se manifester et donc on
appelle des familles à se manifester
pour accueillir l'engagement est assez
réduit d'une certaine manière il s'agit
juste d' offrir un climat même pas
forcément le couvert le couvert une fois
de temps en temps deux ou trois fois
dans la semaine mais mais il ya d'autres
solutions qui seront offertes aux
migrants pour se nourrir et l'objectif
c'est d'être un lieu de parole un lieu
d'écouté un lieu de rencontre mais pas
plus
et au bout d'un mois le migrant c'est
que dans tous les cas il ira dans un
autre lieu
parfois parfois la rue et vous l'avez
dit les appels sont nombreux de gens qui
se manifeste déjà depuis depuis les
annonces d'arrivées des réfugiés c'est
sans précédent cette mobilisation cet
élan de solidarité aussi pour des
migrants oui oui on a eu une forte
mobilisation à certains moments sur par
exemple au moment de la crise d'abidjan
où trallero - rossi on a pas mal de
bénévoles qui se sont à ce moment-là
mollet mais ça n'avait pas était pas de
même nature et comment ça s'explique cvc
lié à quoi la médiatisation de
l'événement aux inquiétudes suscitées un
certain sentiment peut-être aussi de
culpabilité dans certains pays parce que
on se dit que si ça va pas bien en série
en irak c est aussi parce que en
occident on est un petit peu responsable
est probablement un peu de tout ça et on
prend un peu tout ça et en même temps
aussi des images fortes qui nous
marienne monkey qui ont remué c'est
certain cette fois je me réjouis de voir
ces mouvements là maintenant c'est un
peu dommage qu'il faille en arriver à
autant de de force des images pour que
pour qu'on bouge on a maintenant le cuir
assez épais il faut du temps pour réagir
les différentes déclarations de
politique alors certains maires se
manifestent disent oui effectivement je
joue beaucoup en yvelines pas beaucoup
en ils viennent justement c'est là je
voulais en venir certains maires se
manifeste ils sont combien dans les
minimes d'ailleurs à s'être manifesté
officiellement
ça dépend à la minute on se parle le 4
way pour l'instant vous avez 4 sur les
262 communes du département des yvelines
ça fait effectivement assez peu et vous
comprenez ces réticences que peuvent
avoir certains maires les des
différentes déclarations qui sont faites
bah oui je comprends je comprends assez
bien il ya plusieurs manières de
regarder les choses d'une manière à la
fois pratique c'est pas forcément simple
d'oiseaux l'arrivée de migrants
et puis il ya une manière aussi plus
politique d' examiner le sujet à savoir
que vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure on
n'est pas très loin des échéances
électorales
l'arrivée de migrants dans même si
aujourd'hui on commence à avoir pas mal
de personnes qui se disent en faveur de
cette arrivée de 1000 en c-1 reste
encore assez limitée
si on va dans le détail c'est oui oui je
suis pour l'arrivée de migrants mais pas
chez moi
une fois la grâce sarkozy qui dit qu'il
faut une nouvelle politique
d'immigration européenne
au revoir schengen non mais nicolas
sarkozy il est en campagne donc bon
c'est sérieux vous percevez ça comment
bonne ou mauvaise idée
ce que je crois 12 mois est pas et pas
directement sur la politique
politicienne
non mais ça vaut un impact mais la
réalité de ça c'est qu'il faut quand
même bien qu'on réfléchisse d'abord on
regarde bien la planète terre comme une
et entière au niveau du climat au niveau
de l'écologie au niveau des matières
premières au niveau de l'argent au
niveau des cerveaux et inciter on se
refuse à la regarder au niveau de
l'humain bon c'est quand même ce qui
nous réunit tous les humains et dire ben
vous êtes né du mauvais côté c'est
malheureux pour vous ben moi je suis né
du bon ben je suis désolé mais ça
restera comme ça c'est quand même une
attitude qui humainement et difficile à
supporter merci
avec du swing est revenu sur le plateau
au président du secours catholique dans
les yvelines et pour l'ile-de-france
également et nous suivrons bien sûr
cette actualité
l'arrivée des réfugiés et des migrants
au cours des prochains jours et nous
irons sans doute vous voir sur le
terrain agir avec vos belvaux bénévoles
qui sont très mobilisés vous serez le
bienvenu merci beaucoup à vous pour la
fin de ce journal du vendredi quelques
mots d'éducation les étudiants étrangers
de l'université de versailles saint
quentin en yvelines qui ont fait leur
rentrée cette semaine ils viennent des
quatre coins du monde pour suivre des
enseignements dont sept universités
franciliennes fanny bourdilhan
maroc états unis hongrie les soixante
dix étudiants étrangers de nu vs qu
viennent des quatre coins du monde
ils ont posé leurs valises à saint
quentin en yvelines pour un semestre de
6 mois ou une année entière en cette
rentrée l'association étudiante
fraîchement up est là pour les aiguiller
le but d'intégrer les étudiants
étrangers de les faire enfin années mais
leur séjour en france et également de
promouvoir les changes
french me up organise des visites de
campus présente les cours prépare des
repas de bienvenue
tout est fait pour que les étudiants se
repère rapidement dans l'université et
les premières impressions sont plutôt
positives et sceller les campus sont
très bien équipées des ressources sont
disponibles mais aussi le personnel
toujours disponibles répondent à tous
nos questions avant d'attaquer les cours
la semaine prochaine les étudiants
doivent passer par la case
administration une étape angoissante
on a beaucoup à faire les documents de
remplir et donc oui maintenant je suis
un petit peu stressé mais il ya beaucoup
de gens qui sont dans le même cas que
moi donc je suis pas seul oui je suis un
peu stressé parce qu'il faut faire
beaucoup des documents troublants que
des documents et à l'administration en
france et est très compliqué pour
parfaire leur intégration les étudiants
vous recevoir des cours de français afin
de profiter pleinement de leur année
universitaire éducation toujours et
cette semaine nous nous sommes rendus
dans les locaux de l'établissement
musulmans de montigny le bretonneux en
établissements qui rencontrent comme les
autres installés en france un succès
grandissant le reportage est signée
william l tous les jours un tiers de ces
jeunes effectue un trajet de plus de 40
kilomètres pour se rendre à l'école
ils sont inscrits dans l'un des quatre
établissements musulmans privé du
département des yvelines
une offre qui ne répond pas à la demande
en
ici une demande d'inscription sur deux
aboutit en raison du nombre de places
disponibles
nous sommes restreints par les
cotisations scolaires qui sont qui
demeurent élevés en particulier quand
nous sommes hors contrats pour nokia sur
caen hors contrat la cotisation scolaire
est relativement élevé et nous sommes
aussi contraint par l'espace parce que
nous avons un bâtiment qui bien qu'ils
soient grands on ne peut pas accueillir
toutes les demandes et aujourd'hui nous
nous limitons à une classe par niveau
par exemple le 24 août dernier
l'institut de formation de saint quentin
en yvelines a signé son premier contrat
d'association avec l'état pour cette
classe de sixième le directeur de
l'établissement lui espère étendre ce
statut aux autres classes au sens propre
du terme c'est être associé au service
public de l'éducation nationale donc les
établissements privés qui sont sous
contrat d'association veut vraiment dire
qu'ils sont associés à la mission à la
mission d'enseignement aux côtés des
établissements publics
pour être éligible un établissement doit
avoir fonctionné pendant cinq années
hors contrat pour son septième
anniversaire l'institut de formation de
saint quentin en yvelines a pu
bénéficier de ce dispositif qui en plus
des subventions permettra une baisse des
cotisations pour les familles de cette
classe on estime qu'à minima la
cotisation scolaire de 3500 euros à
minima devrait être divisé par deux nous
y voyons un signe supplémentaire de de
reconnaissance de de l'état de nos de
notre démarche et de sa volonté
justement de nous d'appuyer d'appuyer
notre travail
l'institut de formation de saint quentin
en yvelines compte près de 200 élèves
pour des classes allant du cp à la
seconde
en france il n'existe qu'une
cinquantaine d'établissements de ce type
avec encore très peu de contrats en
association avec l'état pour refermer ce
journal un mot de la programmation de
nos confrères de radio sensations et le
retour d'umaga 19h37 du lundi au
vendredi avec à partir de mardi un coup
de projecteur sur les entreprises
innovantes cette semaine citigo
applications de covoiturage zurbains
sûreté des fils vous avez rendez vous du
lundi au jeudi avec florane parfait vous
le savez dorénavant pour le journal 18
heures en direct première rediffusion
19h et 22h30
quant à moi je vous retrouve tous les
vendredis sur les mêmes horaires pour un
résumé
de la semaine et un point sur
l'essentiel du jour très bon week end